Tendría citas médicas durante mis horas de trabajo,
y sabía que necesitaría tiempo libre
para recuperarme de los procedimientos quirúrgicos.
De nuevo, como abogada típica,
hice las debidas diligencias sobre qué esperar del tratamiento.
Lo admito, gran parte fue a través del Dr. Google,
quizás no fue mi mejor movimiento, y no lo recomendaría.
(Risas)
Pero, aunque estaba preparada para los efectos secundarios físicos,
lo que realmente me asustaba era eso llamado "quimio-cerebro".
La quimio-cerebro se presenta en forma de pérdida de memoria,
una incapacidad para concentrarse
y una incapacidad para resolver problemas.
Y si eso me ocurriera a mí,
me preguntaba cómo haría mi trabajo de abogada.
¿Me obligarían a dejar el trabajo?
¿Y cómo podría tratar con mi gerente
sobre los cambios necesarios para mi adaptación laboral
cuando ni yo sabía cómo iba a afectarme?
Tuve suerte por tener un gerente tan comprensivo
que disfrutaba viendo que todo iba marchando bien,
según avanzaba,
en lugar de pedir un plan concreto por adelantado.
Tuve la suerte de que a pesar de no haber oído nunca
sobre este concepto de adaptaciones razonables,
para él, era sentido común.
Pero he aprendido que no es sentido común para todo el mundo.
Cada persona que tome el tratamiento averiguará cómo le afecta
y cuáles son sus limitaciones.
Y aprenderán a adaptarse a ello.
Yo tenía mis trucos y consejos que aprendí con el propio tratamiento,
como, antes de ir a quimio,
necesitan asegurarse de que están muy bien hidratados
y que no están con frío porque ayuda a las enfermeras a encontrar las venas.
Y asegúrense de que no comen ninguna de sus comidas favoritas,
ni antes ni después de la quimio,
porque la van a vomitar y no querrán verla otra vez.
(Risas)
Lo aprendí por las malas.
Y luego estaban los trucos para organizar mi flujo de trabajo.
Programaba la quimio el lunes por la mañana a primera hora.
Sabía que desde el momento en que dejara la unidad de cuidado del cáncer,
tenía cuatro horas antes de que la pantalla de niebla bajara
y comenzara a sentir náuseas.
Así que usaría ese tiempo para limpiar mi bandeja de entrada
y hacer cualquier llamada urgente.
Lo peor de la Indisposición habría desaparecido en aproximadamente 48 horas.
Y luego volvería a conectarme al trabajo desde casa.
Este tratamiento continuó y yo sabía qué esperar.
Pude establecer expectativas razonables con mis socios comerciales
sobre lo que podría hacer
y los periodos de tiempo en los que podría hacerlo.
Pero todavía recuerdo la vacilación en sus voces
cuando venían a pedirme cosas,
y pedirme que hiciera cosas en un tiempo determinado.
Y créanme, estas eran personas
que no tenían miedo de establecer una buena fecha límite.
(Risas)
Me daba la impresión de que no querían ponerme presión extra
mientras estaba con el tratamiento.
Y aunque apreciaba el sentimiento,
de hecho, necesitaba esas fechas límites.
Para mí, eso era algo dentro de mi control
y algo que podía tener bajo control
cuando había tantas cosas que no podía.
Y mientras trabajaba desde casa,
pensaba en cómo los empleadores deberían estar aplicando este concepto
de las adaptaciones razonables en nuestra época actual,
donde uno de cada dos hombres y mujeres australianos
será diagnosticado con cáncer antes de los 85.
Así que, mientras seguimos trabajando más y más hasta una edad avanzada,
las posibilidades de tener una enfermedad grave
mientras estamos activos laboralmente se van incrementado.
Y con la tecnología que nos permite trabajar desde donde sea y cuando sea,
las adaptaciones razonables ya no dependen de
si puedes continuar o no haciéndolo físicamente
dentro de la oficina física.
Las adaptaciones razonables tampoco tratan
de ofrecer un descanso más largo o una silla más cómoda para sentarse,
aunque esas cosas también podrían estar bien.
Por lo menos,
necesitamos aplicar las políticas de flexibilidad y estrategias
que hemos desarrollado para otros escenarios,
como para las personas con responsabilidades familiares.
Pero ¿cómo podemos asegurar que al menos
se esté teniendo una conversación
sobre cuales serían las adaptaciones razonables para ellos
si la primera respuesta de un gerente es decir:
"Oh no, no vuelva al trabajo hasta que esté mejor".
Y una luz se me encendió.
Debe ser obligatorio para los gerentes
tener que sostener estas conversaciones con sus empleados.
Y lecciones de personas como yo,
que realmente se han beneficiado de trabajar con tratamiento,
necesita ser compartido más ampliamente.
Y pensé en lo que podría hacerse para guiar estas conversaciones,
y luego una asombrosa colega mía, Camilla Gunn,
desarrolló un manual para "Trabajar con Cáncer".
Este manual proporciona un marco para aquellos diagnosticados,
sus gerentes, sus cuidadores y sus compañeros de trabajo,
para tratar el tema del cáncer y el apoyo disponible en el trabajo.
Camilla y yo hemos estado en otras organizaciones
para hablar sobre este manual y cómo puede ayudar a guiar
esas conversaciones que de otra forma, sinceramente, serían muy difíciles.
Y me complace decirles que el uso de este manual está aumentando.
Así que, ¿cuál debería ser la primera respuesta de un gerente
cuando alguien le dice que está enfermo
y no sabe cómo va a afectar a su trabajo?
Debe ser esta:
"En la medida que Ud. sea capaz y quiera,
nos encantaría hacer los cambios posibles
para que continúe trabajando durante el tratamiento".
Necesitamos empezar a comprometernos con los enfermos graves
para mantenerlos activos en el trabajo,
mejor que darles de lado paternalmente.
Les he contado mi historia porque quiero que sepan los beneficios
que obtuve al trabajar durante mi tratamiento.
Y también quiero cambiar sus percepciones
si piensan que alguien con tratamiento
es solo alguien aburrido, frágil y alguien que vomita un montón.
Y sí, era cierto algunas veces,
o puede que muchas,
pero también estaba decidida a esforzarme en el trabajo
tanto como lo había hecho siempre.
Y fui capaz de hacerlo porque mi empresa me dio la opción.
Más importante aún, les estoy contando
porque aunque es una elección aparentemente obvia que debe ser dada
no es lo que siempre se ofrece o se promueve.
Y debe serlo.
Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)